[Musique]
bas les pattes fois je n'aime pas
tellement ça moi veut dire parce que je
pense que ça doit partir après ses
ternes elles n'ont ils trouvent ça bien
ouais ouais jour te faire tatouer
ouais papa a partout mais une petite
total sur le bras ça te plairait bien
cet original ça vient de réaliser c'est
tout qu'est ce qui se fait en général
c'est ce sont des chapeaux dvd des
voyous je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de
lien direct entre le sujet tatoué est un
type psychologique particulier de
personnalités notamment
on ne peut pas assimiler directement
tatouages et troubles mentaux tatouages
et délinquance historiquement le
tatouage regroupait des gens d'une même
corporation bon lancre du marin par
exemple c'est bien connu un certain
nombre de personnalités politiques ou de
personnalités royales se faisaient à
tous et il se trouve que maintenant le
tatouage et plus sans encore qu'on
puisse faire de être systématique et
plus l'apanage de gens qui proclament
qu'ils proclament je dis bien une
certaine marginalité
c'est un tronc pour une maison qui sont
ici et puis cuit g8 sur la gamme à moi
comme des fous qui j'ai pas pu
m'empêcher l'égide des guides locaux
sera tatouage sur 9 heures le modèle
vous l'avez choisi comme en bas le
modèle je suis tombé dessus par hasard
sur catalogue
je trouvais ça j invite les faits leur
ont contraint au contrat longtemps
appelé un grand plaisir personnel
c'est quoi c'est de la fierté c'est
socialo un petit peu mais bon j'en suis
fier ce normal je ne serai pas perdre le
ballon séviront là dedans mais je trouve
fiche hier mais surtout c'est surtout un
plaisir personnel
ça nous a coûté combien ben on met ses
rangs l'après aux 2 400 franchir et à
tout âge
enfin sur les deux supports vous
envisagez de vous en faire un an d'eau
par exemple dorsale d'euros et les
modèles là je vois des têtes de mort des
croix c'est pas un peu morbide quand
même
ben cherche c'est le rush même chose non
pour moi l'ont fait l'ombre d'un génial
et ça veut dire quoi
l'actrice y trouve ça beau c'est tout
ces offices
j'ai toujours à répondre je porte dans
mon coeur
il est exact que le tatoué fait ça pour
lui d'une part d'autre part le tatouage
est fait pour être montré mais pas
n'importe qui c'est un truc que je
voulais depuis des années j'ai vu que
tout pouvait faire faire ça coince idée
un peu avec un chargement de ma vie
personnelle mais bon c'est un peu le
symbole des changements sur je peux pas
le voir mais c'est un grand oui le plus
de place sur les personnes et jouer
quelque chose de grand de beau et c'est
ce que c'est pour ça je les fais ici non
seulement le plus tôt de vision sur les
choses vision des gens vision de
division sur un peu toute la société
qu'on vous êtes devenu pessimiste tout à
coup non au contraire
j'étais là je voyais un peu les choses
d'une manière assez secteur puis de
partir de ce moment là je je dise ont
besoin de voir les choses de voir des
gens différents de ses symboles
les gens sont étonnés lorsqu'ils voient
votre ado je suis pas du style avait
même étalé sur les plages en redisant
avec les gens que kim et ricky ce champ
proche qui me connaissent mais c'est sûr
ça surprend pas mal est-ce que vous
pourrez éventuellement un jour vous le
faire enlever
j'y tiens pas n'existe est possible de
vous répondre
il ya une chose qui est évidemment très
importante c'est de se rappeler que le
tatouage est indélébile et que le seul
moyen de de l'enlever se fait au prix
d'une cicatrice qui est souvent
extrêmement disgracieuses donc le
tatouage est une peinture sur soie une
marque sur le corps
une marque qui ne s'en relève pas ou qui
si elle s'enlève remplace en quelque
sorte une cicatrice
et vous avez fait ça commence avec une
aiguille et de l'encré de chine
c'est pas dangereux non propose ça peut
s'infecter mais c'est j'ai pris mes
précautions
moi je trouve que c'est un peu dangereux
parce que après ça je vous rassure
organismes voyez pas ce que c'est le
produit très dangereux
bon faut pas leur en vouloir
c'est tout ce que je te dis si le
tatouage est bien soigné aucun risque
d'infection
est ce les couleurs sont sont élus à des
antiseptiques et bombe à la fin du
tatouage en fait un pansement à la pour
moi cicatrisantes et pendant une semaine
du moins tant qu'il ya des croûtons fait
des pansements
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
regretté que vous les ayez tattoo est
aujourd'hui connue qu'on veut te et dans
ces cas là qu'est ce qui se passe
donc moi je sais pas si je tatoue c'est
que la personne ait décidé mon cas et
décider la réfléchi il fait un tatouage
c'est 40 pas n'importe comment je vais
faire moi c'est ça les gens qu'ils
valent même pas la peine est tatoué et
des gens qui veulent la crème des
tatoués et d'autres pas et c'est quoi
alors c'est une philosophie le tatouage
n'en disons halte à tout lâcher c'est un
tableau mes coups portés à vis du
mouvement qui vous fait un truc le lan
manuele caddeo cette approche ça me gêne
c'est qu'il faut bien réfléchir se faire
faire pour réfléchir une année voire les
modèles revenir un an après bon je
trouve ça mieux que l'irlande main sur
un petit tatouage et leurs notes et
j'apprends un peu partout on a des
petits modèles standards que j'agrandis
paix que je fais à ma manière et on a
aussi on en prend dans des bd en entrant
dans ma tête aussi j'en prends peur tout
vous est dessinatrice à l'origine non
j'ai toujours fait du dessin mais je
suis pas dessiner très seul j'ai fait
trois mois de beaux-arts mais c'est pas
ça qui m'a spécialement au prix
d'efforts j'aurai toujours
qu'est ce que les gens réclament le plus
comme comme croquis comme motif qu
est-ce qui préfère moi ça ça dépend du
personnage en a beaucoup de petit oiseau
des petites fleurs des choses féminine
pour les jambes pour les femmes et
pioneer
c'est très varié à ce départ vraiment
des gens du milieu de l'âge c'est plein
de choses comment est ce que vous avez
décidé de devenir tatoueur bon bah
disons qu'avant je tatoue à la main coup
les copains l'armée tout ça tu bombe un
jour j'ai eu envie de faire quelque
chose à moins qu il puis je me suis
décidé de faire du tatouage ou
artistiques avec des machines autre
chose c'est ce qu'on rend ce monde sait
qui est à 20 vous travaillez avec quoi
alors je travaillais simplement avec des
c'est le vieux style les petites
aiguilles au bout d'un bouchon du bon
vin
non ça fait deux ans que j'ai des
machines et je vais envoyer un sk de
plus en plus des gens qui se font
tatouer toujours et vous tu as toi par
exemple combien de personnes chaque jour
ça c'est suivant la saison en hiver -
n'a pas trop en été ça suivant le temps
mais en moyenne combien par semaine où
on combien par mois ça peut aller de sa
palette de quatre par jour 1 par mois ci
et vous en vivez de ce métier j'essaye
la hongrie c'est difficile quand même
certaines fois une certaine foi non moi
c'est un travail d'artiste heureux des
fossés beaucoup de tatouages à faire des
faux nez
vous avez l'impression que ça devient
une mode on s'est toujours été plus ou
moins de mourir
même les tatouages fait à la main ça
peut être une mode et enfin prix jean
vigo à droite ils seront couvrir par
autre chose
[Musique]